here to respond he's the author of guilt
by accusation Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz you know I might imagine
these are people that perhaps over the
years have liked you and respected you
this crosses the line lockhart in
particular crosses a line because really
that they're gonna compare you to hitler
they're gonna go that far because you
dared to have a different opinion based
on really sound knowledge the
constitution our founders our framers
and you laid it out and they just hate
the fact that they disagree with you and
i guess you were so effective well i
think the reason they really came after
me as they saw after I made my talk and
after I answered those questions many of
the Senators gathered around me
including Democrats and they all said
how they were impressed by my
constitutional presentation and remember
that the point I was making was about
the Senators what I said is if you have
mixed motives if you are in the public
interest you're trying to help the
public but you're also trying to get
reelected
according to shift and Nadler that's a
crime if you have any inkling of motive
to help yourself get reelected they call
that corrupt and they say even a tiny
amount of motives to help yourself makes
you into a criminal and makes you
impeachable and I turn to all the
senators and I said everybody in this
room every senator every politician
everywhere always has one eye toward
re-election another eye toward the
public interest they almost always think
it's the same they also think their own
election is in the public interest you
can't make that an impeachable offense
but I never ever said or suggest that or
implied that a president could do
anything he wants if he thinks his
election will help the public interest
that was just a lie a distortion and it
was stated by Schiff it was stated by
Nadler it was stated by Schumer it was
stated by virtually everybody on CNN and
MSNBC and it was just categorically
false aid was never discussed at all in
the phone call but corruption was
discussed the Ukraine it the only in
fact witness said that
nothing no quid pro quo Ukraine got all
of their money they did nothing they
promised to do nothing even if the
president said to Bolton or anybody else
I'd like to punch this guy in the face
and not give him a penny unless he does
a B or C it didn't work out that way and
people can't be punished for their
thoughts
I don't think professor Ken they well
what I worry about is the same theory
could have could put Joe Biden in jail
if somebody could claim that 99% of
Biden's motivation and getting the
prosecutor fired was the public interest
in preventing corruption but 1% in the
back of his mind he was thinking maybe
this could help my son a little bit
because he works for the company that's
being investigated
according to Nadler and Schiff that
would be enough comment second gets
impeached so a vice president the united
snakin gets impeached vice president the
United States says to a country fire the
prosecutor or you're not getting a
billion dollars in aid you've got six
hours son of a B they did now who's the
prosecutor prosecutors he knows is
investigating his son his son has no
experience in Ukraine oil gas or energy
but he's being paid millions eighty
three thousand a month average American
family four makes less than fifty four
thousand a year now can you name one
company professor one just that would
ever pay somebody with zero experience
millions of millions of dollars can you
does that pass the smell test cuz even
hunters said I don't know why they paid
me well is it because your father's the
vice president probably it's certainly
relevant and if they do get witnesses I
would think if there's a defense lawyer
the first witness I would want to call
would be hunter by right hang on one
second now the brother or not professor
hang on one second the president is
talking about Adam Schiff once listening
extreme late-term abortion because
Republicans believe that every child
a sacred gift from God
Democrats are now the party of high
taxes high crime open borders late term
abortion socialism and blatant
corruption no matter how you cut it
that's what it is the Republican Party
is the party of the American worker the
American family the American Dream and
the late great Abraham Lincoln you know
that right Abraham remember I always
said I could be more presidential than
any other past president other than
perhaps all right packing we gotta go
back to this in a second professor I
want to really ask you that question
though when it can you name any company
professor you're a very smart man
no any company that would ever pay
anybody millions of millions 83 thousand
a month when they have zero by their own
admission on tape in an interview with
ga0 experience I can't think of any
company that would do that unless it's
to device the president was there by
access yeah yeah no of course
and nobody without that and that's why
it's worth investigating and that's why
if there were to be witnesses he would
have to be called because the president
was entitled to say on the basis of this
information don't you think this should
be an investigation and by the way even
if he did say it on the day that Biden
announced when a person announces for
president that subjects him to greater
scrutiny by the media by everybody else
so of course you're gonna get greater
scrutiny if you're running for Vice
instead of having been just a has-been
former vice president you don't need
scrutiny but if you're running from
presidents have to have more scrutiny so
by the way he didn't mention Bernie or
Elizabeth mention Lincoln professor I
got a role because of region I got a
role